Once in October, Jung Nail Explosion
Bundled 4 Men Hundreds of days immediately Foreign
Li Jung Jae 4
Overseas Dealer Feeling
Oh
Thank you so much for giving me such a meaningful award
Ah I should have attended but
ah what at the port
There are so many things that I have to work on,
so I can't attend this way, so I
'll greet you with a video.
I just want to say I'm sorry for that peak.
And
I love
the squid game so much.
Oh,
I'm studying. Oh, everyone
tells me that I always do snow at the beginning of the season.
Please wait a little bit.
Oh, and once again, thank you.
Thank you again Netflix
Oh and again
Oh
Squid Pen Only that game Oh
please love the game Thank you to all the audience
One people
[Applause]
[Music]